je m'appelle jean daniel bouchard je
suis agriculteur et danseurs
j'ai commencé la danse à la firme j'ai
toujours été dans la sixième génération
de la m
quand j'étais jeune j'ai commencé à
faire la traite je devais avoir 9 en
disant j'ai fait le programme sport
études à la polyvalente d'arvida pour
mon cégep suis parti à l'extérieur c'est
donc parti à winnipeg pour faire ma
formation professionnelle en danse
j'ai dansé dans les compagnies pendant
au moins neuf ans je vais juste danser
je pense et on fait pourtant partie tout
le temps tournait tout à l'extérieur de
la manne est bien là dessus plus est
établi arrêtez de tout temps bouger
c'est là que je veux c'est comme si ben
je me répète reçoit revenir un peu chez
nous mon père y avait pas de relire mes
frères de plus ne pas vraiment intéressé
à prendre la relève de la ferme
c'est vraiment lourd je pense que ça a
été ma mendicité j'ai vraiment commencé
à me dire qu'ils rue c'est ça que je
veux faire aussi mais je voulais pas
lâcher le ballet non plus la danse
classique et contemporain alors j'ai
aussi fondé avec le doute dans sa une
compagnie de danse au
saguenay-lac-saint-jean je fais les deux
en même temps j'avais un côté danse est
aussi l'agriculture
[Musique]
l'un complète est vraiment même si
salaire que non mais c'est si c'est
vraiment opposés mais des fois les les
contraires s'attirent en agriculture
c'est vraiment plus terre-à-terre c'est
plus la physique un poussin fait de la
danse bal est que plus à les laisser
aller son imagination
même si c'est physique aussi puis la
danse d'année la souplesse d'une
souplesse qui nécessaire en agriculture
pour pas de blessé en agriculture c'est
des mouvements plus répétitif non tirs
35 vaches deux fois par jour avec ça
fait 70 squat que je fais à tous les
jours puis bande ans ça ça me garde en
forme trouver un équilibre là dedans ça
va être sur le dos des fixant le sait
bien c'est possible bien deux poids
lourds se concentrer sur une chose parce
que m'amener ça devient trop je trouve
j'aurais pu me concentrer vers un plus
plus à la danse pour aller plus loin et
encore plus grands danseurs ou bien se
concentrer vraiment juste sur la femme
peut grandir grandir tout acheter des
terres la manif anti fasciste grossir
pour grossir mais là c'est quoi le but
le but c'est d'être heureux au bout du
compte
puis moi ce qui me remets c'est de faire
la danse puis faire l'agriculture
maintient avoir les deux
[Musique]